hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Pony Island now don't be
deceived by what you see in front of you
the childish demeanor just hides a
darker demon lurking within the same
demon that wants to burst out of our
chests and consume us from within and
then destroy our entire town and family
in society as a whole and we'll corrupt
all of our politicians and everyone in
power well anyway now that I've shut up
properly welcome to Pony island a game
that is deceiving and has nothing to do
with any sort of tiny pony and no one
cares who owns them this is a different
type of game one that is made by
systemic tech incorporated if I can talk
properly we're gonna get through this
video just fine in case ah I thought
this was another menu but I'm keen on
your secrets I haven't seen this game
before what is that I want a free ticket
hell yeah ooh that is weird
that was a realistic hand in front of my
face I mean I've got a realistic hand
here but I'm not sure what this is
supposed to be advanced art ah I cannot
turn off the cheerful facade anti-align
losing fix Start menu ah
I fixed the Start menu but broke this
options menu I'm boned hey we're in a
temper - oh God obscure options not able
oh so you can't turn that off
oh but I can put the ah that's much
better
all right Oh their eyes are open now
they see everything
let's get good okay like I said I've
never seen this game I just know from
the trailer on Steam that it gets weird
but this is getting weirder than I
thought it would
uh-oh ha what is there supposed to be
Boeing
movie - boom Oh something's now right
here oh now we hit load the game maybe I
wonder if eventually the screens just
gonna go reflective black and I must see
my docile face staring back at me from
in front of get out of the way of the
loading bar I'm trying to make a stupid
joke ah oh that's not gonna work if I
die
yeah okay now we're making progress
okay oh you just hot let's get you I
don't if it was going to work I tested
it a thousand times it's almost time to
play okay
welcome to boney Island see you're
giving me mixed signals here here I
thought you were mad at me for fixing it
but now you're seen do
is that a button background
oh [ __ ] am I supposed to be
oh-hoh well that doesn't seem natural
huh with the artistic a little silly oh
the articulation physics don't seem to
be properly calibrated
yeah okay so far so fancy and free
I feel fine oh boy I love this already
by the way I must say oh it's a Mario
flag I got huge success I am blasting
through the Lord's how many little am I
gonna get I get so good I can want to
thumbs right overcome what wonderful I
think I'm gonna continue when it gets to
why is my favorite one lon okay so a
little lost but number one love this
whole style of like alternate reality
game or augmented reality game thing
going on here kind of a meta scenario
with the realistic person outside play
Oh
last whoa
okay so maybe I got a baby I gotta wait
until goes to war love one warden in the
mean walk I just get to walk in the
grill my own suit ice oh yes
keep your moderation boys on me in the
comments down below
Rommels there oh wow I saw you over
there oh I'm gonna get all the tickets
hell yeah
well yeah get a realistic hand in there
oh yeah okay in overflow error
experience the rest of Pony Island
insert your soul to continue paywall
null so check soul validates also
required okay
well maybe I need to do a little bit of
this and this and this and then I won't
have to pay my soul eyes nice do not
proceed hell yeah oh did I broke it my
horrible habit of breaking games have
followed me to this one
that didn't seem to be doing nothin BAM
okay oh hello missingno it's how you
Mewtwo Oh Pony galaxy oh yes please we
okay what am I playing pony galaxy Oh
chip it's all [ __ ] I'm terrible at this
is so weird
this games within games within games
within games why are we playing so many
goddamn games I bet if I get a high
score on this I'm gonna get another
ticket but I don't have nearly enough
information I have been trapped in this
game for what feels like an eternity
anthis playing help endless testing I am
level 7 8 109 to remember that number 7
8 109 to write that down for me to type
it in the comments below
7 8 109 to and I'm trying to piece
together star oh oh I see ha ha ha ha ha
Oh what was that
hello hello hello my prayers are
answered hello how are how are you how
are you hello I didn't mean to do that
I'm a prisoner of this machine so am i I
do not want to panic but it's possible
that we may share the same fate oh noes
I have a plan but I do not have the
means to execute it you must help me how
are you will you help me yes
what was that oh hi hello hello huh
you must feel good about yourself you
hacked your way out of pony island why I
don't know the positive feedback loop
for completing mundane jumping task
wasn't engaging enough for you know I'm
a pro gamer c1u copyright at AI f
hashtag are you just had to what don't
message anyone else on here now my plan
there are three core Program Files that
this entire operating system depends on
deleting a single one will lessen the
power but that he wields but we must
delete all three to truly escape do you
understand me
No ah you just who are you talking to no
yes no you you are so arrogant I've been
making changes to Pony Island we will
see what you think of it this time I
asked you not to talk to him oh jeez
okay you are mine now say yes master no
[ __ ] oh oh whoa hey y'all God type in
[ __ ] oh here I'm a hundred percent F uck
oh all right fine then I'll play your
game you rogue you [ __ ] rogue see if
you're too good for my game this time we
will see I'm not doing that
hands are up here thumbs up the bum as
per yuge
okay ah good a pentagram system tactic
corporate Satan tech I see that okay say
tantek okay oh they're crying zeroes and
ones
Oh No aah I know oh oh I just had it it
was just in my brain it was just in my
brain
hang on ah man why didn't I take a
picture of that I didn't think it'd be
too much seven eight one seven eight 109
- BAM
okay so that's not correct there so that
doesn't go there
let's go - oh we can go Don's oh no hey
hi oh this looks like some Kody code I
don't know how to solve this there seems
to be a problem here
a little doink then a Twinkie Twinkie
yeah hell yeah give me that ticket give
me that ticket baby I don't know what
these tickets do but I'm getting a whole
hell of a lot of them all right let's go
into this game
if loading times nice
you thought that was too easy
how what do you think now oh I can't
jump high or they'll get ha ha ha my
game is challenging but fair come back
with it
okay I don't I don't know about that
okay in a listing well [ __ ] Knicks ah
put it back but if I okay cheerful
facade
well that's broke seed fan star Angie oh
boy or all these oh that's just gone now
okay
ah okay so I need to spell out Advanced
Options nice fan story oh hell yeah
jeez - Morgan I blew up the heart why
did I have to blow up the heart
I got another ticket though good for my
advanced gameplay old prototype options
keyblades okay unlimited free well give
me that free well whoa whoa ah [ __ ] okay
so it's a boozled ah okay oh okay
it's really useless Oh
cheater no no I won't let you cheat
oh come on man touching - oh okay
how am I gonna enough yeah that's not
enough oh [ __ ] I need more Oh it stops
oh look carry on Ike hey hey yeah I beat
your system bro I'll beat your system
yeah
give me that give me that I want it I
want it I want it I want it I want it so
badly try to click on it I want it so
badly
okay all right okay okay so I gotta do
this one now boink see then down try
some of this [ __ ]
boink make that [ __ ] nice and bigger
boink and then another point here okay I
got it look good okay y'all then over
y'all go with this for now right
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba yes pony lasers Wow
oh Jesus
holy [ __ ] I love laughs go back in and
turn that off
you can't weigh with that laser man
security settings rental allowed to die
on earth Oh help me I don't what I don't
know what these numbers mean hey hello
how are you so am i oh no that's me oh
that's me
ah okay coach door just take one I don't
know what this is are these game codes
for steam I don't know I don't know I
don't know okay I'm gonna go now all
right cool let's try it
Wow oh man now my pony's getting too
powerful for you
so Papa's gonna lag the computer back
I've got some very polite laser blasts
oh wow oh good I don't even need my
hands to play point of easy-peasy okay
cool exactly cheating I'd say oh geez is
that a meter on my body that says how
much laser potential I got because I got
a lot of laser India I just gotta
channel it out don't make me fire my
rear laser that's the one that really
doesn't it I hope this is hurting you in
some way although that does sound like a
malicious thing that's saying how they
say it out loud
you
[Music]
ah I made it in it seems he is
distracted this is our chance
oh I don't know if I trust you that
portal will take us to a core file I
didn't even read the rest of it I just
trusted you endo right in this is it
this is the core file that looks like a
daemon over there it's a kind of defense
that he set up to guard the file
shouldn't be a problem since it's locked
up strange let's unlock it how do we
unlock it game do that Oh awesome
it's awesome logic I don't know if I
like Azazel logic
hello are you
[Music]
then
yeah kind of a little bit I mean I don't
want to say anything about your stupid
game in your stupid way of life and your
stupid existence in this stupid computer
and the fact that you're stupid I
thought it might've been a little easy
I'll get you I'll get you four house
dollars in hey hey wait a minute
hey wait a minute we're fighting up
battle here oh I see how this is ah you
you lose stupid dummy child's play
yeah beat you yeah you'll not break
another I don't know about that let's
fight come on come on what you got it's
all we're gonna be doing oh yeah
I need ah okay so we're playing aha so
we're playing a clever ruse so I
definitely need this one here
oh you says ah ha ha I win I win I win
I'm a winner I'm a winner I'm a winner I
win
ah my mom would be so proud of me mom if
you're watching this hi are you proud of
me text me if you're proud of me
thank you everybody in the comments just
ignore this conversation but I am the
greater mind I don't know I beat you
twice now
all right let's rise again Josie's have
to go here nice I needed that thank you
I actually did boink let's move that up
there yeah no no I don't like that no I
don't think that belongs there
definitely need that one there okay
you down there perfect okay you're doing
me a great service that went over there
okay easy peasy lemon squeezy
nice nice nice and I win I win I win
I'm the greatest that ever was I know
exactly how to play this game that I've
never played before what are you doing
hi well master you mean uh mister [ __ ]
over there
you mean mister doesn't know how to type
yeah he's a easy yeah he's a bit of it
was oh those are things that cannot move
ah very interesting so I'm gonna put the
dumped ones right here oh I needed that
you ass
yes nice non moveable I'm gonna move
this in then on mobile good one but not
quite if you wanted to be a not dad -
not a dick then maybe he shouldn't have
been the man and bang boom bang boom
bang boom bang go I know how to beat you
Azazel is this really how you're
programmed to be that much suck and
death fool your profit is oh I don't
know about that you're literally a demon
I don't know what could be worse plus
I'm pretty sure I could just walk you
have been deceived yeah actually I'd
actually be willing to bet that he's not
lying about that whoever's talking to me
probably wants to take over pony island
and there's something else going on here
I'm just a guy that walked up to a
really funky arcade oh is this where I
can see my reflection in the mirror ooh
say tantek cool
ah core file missing cool okay so I'm
gonna end this episode here I'm gonna do
a full playthrough this game because
this phenomenally interesting so thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know what you thought of it down the
comments below and as always I will see
you in the next video a part of me is
like okay but then I actually have to
try to start your life with all the
knowledge you currently have but you
can't recreate the relationships you
currently have